hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
Freddy's 4 now everyone has told me that
night 6 is going to be absolutely
unbelievably terrible and I'm never ever
ever going to be able to beat it but I
know what I'm doing and I'm kind of
practiced a little bit and I've got my
lucky flannel on so I can't imagine that
it'll be that bad but it is important to
note this is version 1.01 which means
that Scott did release an update of some
sort and something has changed I don't
know what but whatever I highly doubt
that it'll matter once we get into it
because it's probably gonna be just
still just as hard cuz one thing about
this seriously these games are hard
what's different now I don't even know
I'm just gonna operate under the
assumption that all the other ones are
engaged I guess oh man I don't know I
don't know what to expect I'm gonna die
I'm gonna die I wanna die I'm gonna die
whoa that was quick on you all right
what do we got what do we got oh okay
all the other animatronics are back I
don't know if that means the golden
Freddy is gonna be here yeah that's
right you better back off Wimbley
families leave me alone oh that's right
back up back up back up back I'll crap
already Jesus all right come on what do
you got foxy oh boy
okay well that's something we have to
worry about
hello snip snippy oh crap
what the blows that don't get out here
hmm okay
Makka pakka Bona BAE's on the Left I
Betty's on the Left what I heard that
okay oh my god yeah oh yeah yeah foxy
god damn it's gonna be rough whoo oh boy
this is gonna be tough on how okay good
enough good enough I don't think I can
waste time to get them all the way oh
yeah yeah okay back babies come on girl
again those guys are assembling pretty
quickly okay I might have a little more
time than I thought on this one okay
maybe not maybe not maybe not I have no
idea okay so far so good
chicas not being terribly active which
is good whoo that was breathing
that was a weird different sounding
breathing I don't like that one oh man
they are getting super active on that
okay so far so good
okay good enough good enough good enough
come on
mm-hm
boy howdy that was delayed
nothing I'm patient okay good good good
good good good good good good good good
he gotta getta getta getta getta getta
getta getta give you okay fine a high so
far it oh that was not enough that was
not enough oh my don't know okay got ya
got here I think behind me I need to get
out of here get out of here
what was that oh my first wrong button
there oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
oh boy
okay damn it's not so bad
okay good enough good enough good enough
get out of here
get out there okay right right right
come on come on come on okay okay okay
oh boy
my heart's beating a million times a
minute okay good good good good good
good good good
check a check to go okay that was
nothing at all nothing at all nothing at
all can I hear okay good good good good
okay good good good good
that golden Freddy that might have been
golden Freddy step seven
oh my god did they switch it up oh my
god they switched it up didn't they
oh my god dad all they did oh they did I
called it they switched it up okay so
4:00 a.m. they switch it up to okay 4:00
a.m. it goes ah I got it okay I got it I
got it okay
I can do this okay all right okay I can
do this oh I know the crying children
need to go okay
fine fine fine we're fine we're fine
we're fine we're fine
whoa whoa whoa wasn't expecting that
whoa whoa Nelly there oh he's back to a
plushy good goody goody gumdrops
dammit that wasn't as much time as I
wanted to give okay it's fine no it's
fine it's fine it's fine
whoa Nelly whoa Nelly whoa Nelly
oh boy okay fine fine out here get out
of here get out of you're gonna do okay
here we go switch gears okay switch
gears here we go oh here we go here we
go here we go here we go here we go yep
yep yep
okay okay
keep slipping back and forth Oh back oh
boy
front front front front front hmm sounds
like the left switch together damn it oh
crap behind behind nope front front
front front come on oh crap that's not
good that's not good
Oh God Oh Oh
I thought I was dead come on that was
that was bad that was bad those back
come on come on come on just left left
left left left left one one one one sup
love loving someone lovin
oh crap he's left left left left left
left left left lemma okay I think that's
okay because yes ooh baby
lucky flannel baby looking vital up in
this business
open the beards niche it's hopping the
biz Wow my heart was going
I've got like so much adrenaline was
this what is this can you hear me yes I
can hear I don't know if you can hear me
I can hear I'm sorry you're broken since
about the bite
we're still your friends do you still
believe that I'm still here I will put
you back together oh my god that's what
the hell oh okay cool
what does that mean what does that mean
well I know it means okay so obviously
that was like a flatline for the kid
after he passed away and then like the
golden Freddy or Fred bear was saying he
was gonna put him back together in that
he was gonna like carry on his spirit
inside the souls of the machines and
that's how it became haunted but it
still doesn't explain the murders like
the murders of the children and how like
maybe the children are referring to like
his older brother by me his older
brother is still like a child but this
child is just a very young child I don't
know there's so much mystery to this
okay so people have said I've seen that
there's actually up to an eighth night
so there's a seventh night somewhere
here and there might be more extras that
I can go through
oh here we go Oh let me see if like I
don't think that yeah it's still a
mystery so that might be in the next one
making fredbear oh that's cool oh my god
that's so vicious holy crap don't look
at me that's creepy oh that's nasty
whoa alright then
okay at least it's a little quieter here
dang it's just those jump scares whoa I
never saw that one holy crap yeah oh
yeah that's right the cupcake oh hey
how's it going there cutie alright so
that was that fun with plushtrap I'm
guessing that's just playing the game I
don't need to play it again and then
nightmare which I'm assuming is a whole
nother game mode and that's what I'm
gonna get to in the next episode
nightmare but I'm gonna see a flood with
flood trap maybe will get me forward a
little more in the game so either way oh
man so weird
so it I am really really happy with the
way this game has gone to switch to
audio and that moment of apprehension
thinking and the panic it's great it's
all what I've wanted it to be now I
won't make any conclusions yet cuz
obviously the series is not over but I'm
gonna try nightmare mode which might be
the 20/20 mode or maybe there's a secret
night that I don't know about let me
know in the comments down below thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always I will see you
in the next video